hi everyone and welcome to another apac
Android developer office hours session
thanks for joining us today we have Rios
k here from Tokyo Japan hello hey Rios k
and Tony Tan has just joined us as well
from from hong kong hi guys and I'm
Ankur Kotwal and I'm joining in from
Sydney Australia so we actually don't
have a lot of questions today so
hopefully that means that we are global
teams have been doing a good job of
answering questions or that people are
still just really enjoying themselves
after i/o anyways let's get started with
the questions that we have we have the
the moderator thread so the first
question is I'll read it out
word-for-word and then I'll interpret it
says how to make a Google+ or YouTube
style slide menu it is not include in
the Android design but I think it is
good is it included in the API if not
why not so my understanding of this
question is it's referring to the
slide-out menu that you get on the
left-hand side now in the Google+ and
the air youtube apps and basically it's
a new kind of design style that we see
is getting popular and we're obviously
starting to adopt it in our in our
official apps right now there is a there
is nothing available for developers to
build that themselves having said that
we're actually planning to update the
Android design guide to show you how to
build it yourself we'll probably be
providing some sample code to go with it
and then that way it will be available
to you so stay tuned it is coming
alright the next question is on Android
Beam journey yeah so let me take this
one so the question was we are excited
when knowing that Android Beam is having
an upgrade doing the io 2012 any reason
on why Android Beam pick NFC plus
bluetooth not MF
c + Wi-Fi direct light s beam to control
device paired and connected like
controlling the nessus kill um well
first of all I don't think like we are
in favor one technology over another but
that's said there is really something
advantage of using a Bluetooth also let
me highlight them so the first one is in
terms of like power consumption boo
tooth is really doing very well
sometimes even better than Wi-Fi another
reason of choosing bluetooth is when you
connect our with to Wi-Fi direct you
have to connect disconnect from the on
the Wi-Fi network so that's that you
still can connect to the internet using
radio connection like using your 3g or
4g radio but but they there is some kind
of user not smooth user experience there
and finally a wife I'd erectus is
available in I believe in in ICS and so
in terms of compatibility a boo tooth
mfc is is probably much more compatible
in all other Android devices hope answer
a question oh thanks Tony so the next
question is a use one about project
butter so just a quick introduction
project butter is one of the big
undertakings that we had in in jelly
bean and it was really all about making
the user interface buttery smooth and
highly responsive so Rios k why don't
you handle take this one sure the ok
that question was ok i am reading it we
have seen project butter in action at I
all we would like to know if there is
anything we should do to make our
applications better by sinking our
custom fields with vsync is there
anything that we need to do
the tree to enable this feature and we
saw the question from bangalore india
and i think that there are several
things i would like to clarify and first
of all this project butter is something
that you can relate without changing
your code so it means that without doing
anything on the living and above your
application should be already behaving
much smoother than people and having
said that there are several ati's that
you can take added in order to take
further advantage of this precinct and
that the i think that the most typical
operation that you'd like to do whenever
we think happens probably you directs to
simply invalidate viewable and actually
that this android animation framework
already has the method for that and it
is called deal dot post invalidate on
animation when you say that the soon
after this action of the disparate
gamestats um you get invalidated I love
it Alicia sorry now my mistake sorry
okay yeah so this so there are several
other methods on bill like post on
animation or post on animation today
aside from pasta invalidate on animation
and you can use these new methods these
cross reverberates under the animation
framework and they are automatically
synchronized with Vince pissing on jelly
bean and these are simple API to use and
also if you are rendering a
some difference read outside of your own
don omar shred possibly you may be doing
some customers entering using opengl or
something in those cases you may not be
actually using under the animation
framework still you can decorate this
jelly bean project butter by using our
new api called choreographer and this is
a totally new API that we introduced
studying API level 16 and you can
basically say that the this
choreographer api is you can use when
you drag to put your coat back
synchronized with this basic timing so
you can do whatever you want at the
beginning of this display REM cycle
using this callback mechanism and so
this does not depend on android
animation of air max so this is doable
even if you are doing anything you would
like without standard giving mechanism
not words one explanation I was able to
offer for this question I hope this
answers your question thank you right
well it looks like we have someone
that's joined us from the hangar okay
Alan I finally yeah hi nice to meet you
so do you have any questions for us
actually I was looking for but kind of
properties and what are you discussing
the I thought maybe I think I can chip
in I'm sorry it's a little bit hard to
hear you oven could you repeat what you
said I said I said the double looking at
something and I was thinking maybe i can
ship in what are you guys discussing
about okay well you've come in at an
interesting time because we've just sort
of run out of questions too okay go
answer so yeah you probably want to
catch the youtube recording afterwards
and catch up on the questions that we
already answered so
yeah if you have any of your own
questions at the moment this is a good
time to ask if there's anyone I can see
that we've got a number of viewers on
the stream so if you have any questions
that you'd like asked please post them
to the thread we are ready and waiting
to it to answer um so part of an why we
have you here have you had a chance to
look at the youtube videos from google
i/o no okay not yet okay have you done
any Android development yourself yeah
basically we have very few lives one is
basic that deep is at clear light and
basic if that ever you're publishing
apps okay publishing apps all right
already put on the market on plane sorry
I missed that let's see that you're dead
haven't we are their private builds okay
fair enough um looks like people are
fairly quiet today really we've got 15
viewers at the moment and it looks shy
so I guess another yeah I guess we
should give them some time to go over
all the youtube videos like we have an
all new contents after Google i/o so
let's give them some time to digest and
probably next week we will have more
questions yeah I hope so so will will be
doing this weekly just like our
colleagues in the US as well as in amia
so our European colleagues there so
we'll post up a moderator link for next
week and if there isn't anything else
right now I guess we will see you next
time alright sounds good alright thanks
probably thanks Tony and thanks for your
skate okay thank you here I everyone
thank you very much